I'm Jake Decker and I'm reading for a
viewer Mike Epstein Gears of War as a
series has always required tactical
planning understanding how to read a
battlefield to find ideal cover and
outflank your opponent is just as
essential as your trusty Lancer still
it's surprising just how well gears
translates to a turn-based strategy RPG
gears tactics captures the chaotic gory
rollercoaster energy generated by the
shooters even as your focus turns from
playing a cog to maintaining the machine
[Music]
technically tactics is a prequel but it
really feels like a throwaway story from
the expanded cannon though connections
to the overarching Gear saga
particularly Gears v abound Gears
tactics story is simple and mostly
detached from the larger franchise so
while the plot takes a backseat Gears
tactics cleverly twist the formula of
the modern strategy RPG creating
scenarios that fit the Gears mold all
the XCOM inspired mechanics are their
action points that can be used to move
or attack half in full cover and
defensive overwatch positioning if
you've ever so much thought of the word
tactics game the flow will feel
comfortable it will also feel incredibly
familiar to Gears fans nearly every
single mechanic and system from the core
series appears in turn-based form and
most of them fit remarkably well downing
enemies than executing them becomes
vital as it awards your squaddies extra
action points rushing in with the Lancer
chainsaw is an aggressive way to clear
paths through an enemy but only if you
can reach them without taking overwatch
fire not only do the mechanics and the
stylistic flourishes of the Gears series
make sense in a turn-based environment
but you can build strategies around them
likewise almost every enemy type is
imported from the shooter series with
stats and traits that transpose that
real-time action identities into a more
stats driven turn-based form wretches
still get in your face creating
dangerous distractions some of the more
advanced enemies like boomers will drop
their powerful explosive weapons
creating an opportunity for you to turn
the enemy's heavy firepower back on them
however in a few cases the gears like
systems clash with the tried-and-true
x-com like ideas making them feel
unnecessary for example you're able to
build up a squad of over 20 years
through story missions but many missions
require that you use the small set of
core story characters so you rarely use
more than a few alternates when the two
identities merge you get scenarios that
mimic the flow and intensity of combat
arenas and gears shooters even as they
play out in a more controlled formulaic
way on paper your standard squad of four
gears are always outnumbered and
outgunned each wave of enemies carries a
certain momentum which a Vokes a moment
of doubt as to whether or not you even
have a chance to survive scouring
derelict cities and abandoned factories
of varying shapes and sizes you'll move
from cover to cover trying to put your
team in the best possible position to
take on whatever is just around the
corner in true Gears fashion even if you
can handle what you find off the bat
there's always another wave of
reinforcements or a new emergence hull
popping up spawning enemies behind your
back
though the situation never adds up in
your favor there's almost always a
solution to the threat you're facing
whether you choose to dig an embrace
from a defensive position or clear
through the locusts toward you have to
employ your strategic acumen reactively
combining your squads moves and attacks
in the most efficient sustainable way
possible each character can act three
times per turn on top of that
specialized perks in gear often give you
plenty of opportunities to earn extra
health or moves even when you feel like
you've been backed into a corner there's
always a move that will give you a small
chance of doing something to turn the
tide crack the mission wide open and
shift the momentum back your way
when it works in that one cautious shot
turns into a 20 move assault it feels
like you pulled off one of those
reactionary Hail Mary's schemes Marcus
Fenix seems to pull off an every gear
set piece the beauty of gears tactics is
that those maneuvers are entirely
contingent on how you develop your
character as you develop each of the
gears classes you're able to augment
them with skills and passive perks from
a large skill tree each section of the
tree gives you a different set of
abilities and bonuses that encourage you
to use them in specific ways creating a
team that complements each other in how
you approach situations tactically not
only feels like progress but growth as
you come in your own as a commander your
gears find their footing as soldiers at
the same time though that specificity
intensifies how repetitive the game
starts to feel though the campaign took
over thirty five hours to complete there
are only a handful of mission types
including a king of the hill style point
control a turn limited character rescue
and myriad excuses to kill every locust
in sight while many are engaging
challenging and exciting the first
couple times they start to wear thin as
you repeat them over and over again even
with modifiers and optional objectives
to spice things up there's no
replacement for actual objective and
level variety over the long haul the
only truly novel missions are a trio of
boss battles where you square off
against some of the series biggest
baddest enemies in addition to the boss
monsters who have large sweeping attacks
that forced you out of cover you'll have
to fight waves of standard enemies who
aren't exactly easy to handle you could
argue that these long winded fights are
the epitome of the Gears tactics format
every turn requires you to react to new
potentially game-ending circumstances
while also moving towards your objective
and planning for what your opponents
will do next really they're too much of
a good thing the big attacks feel more
restrictive than all inspiring and the
drawn-out spectacle minimizes the
momentum that pushes you through the
standard missions
though Gear's tactics wears itself a
little thin by the end of its protracted
campaign the rush of pulling together a
victory from the jaws of defeat carries
an exciting chaotic energy unlike most
strategy games playing well doesn't
necessarily make you feel like a
mastermind so much as though you've
cheated death every successful plan even
a last-ditch effort feels like a small
stroke of genius
that's no small feat
you